Alhamdulillah.
Fore!
[Silence]
So here we have a narration
which was collected by Bkari
on the authority of Abdullahbn. and both
of them were companions. He and his
father
Abdullahb
and his father
A and his uncle Hishe
was also a companion.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam as a
matter of fact said
He says that
and his brother, the two sons of Al are
believers. Now, here's what's
interesting. Their father
was one of the most terrible human
beings to ever walk the streets of
Mecca.
And that's where he got his name from.
foreign.
[Silence]
And so
their father was a very terrible man. He
was one of the most
one of the most
aggressive antagonists of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
and this is where he got his nickname
from his namesake. He's referred to as
al meaning the the defiant
because he was so defiant and
disobedient
to Allah and his messenger sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. But his sons Almar and
his brother were believers.
And Almar had a son named Abdullah. And
Abdullah is one of the great scholars of
the companions.
And he was young. He was a young man
during the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam's lifetime.
And he later migrated to Hashem after
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam's death and he passed away
there and as a matter of fact the medhub
of
in the earlier years of
fk and the science of in those
areas in Amg and so forth. They were
largely based around the teachings of
Abdullahbni.
Abdullah here narrates to us a narration
that has three sentences.
The narration tells us three things. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam gives us
three points here.
The first point he gives is
[Silence]
to be
the camel inch.
[Silence]
Many people are under the misconception
that
calling to Islam or even teaching Islam
is the sole
domain of the scholars only.
You have to be a scholar to teach
anything. And this is incorrect.
And the efforts of the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam was always
to close that chasm between the general
masses of the Muslim and the scholarship
of Islam
where we don't want to have a cast
system where these are the scholars up
here then the rest of the people down
here the people up here they are the
sole proprietors of knowledge and then
the people down here they don't know
anything all they know is what they are
told. This is not the model that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam taught.
This is the situation that banel found
themselves in
where the laymen were
very late.
They knew nothing.
They knew nothing of their own book.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"And so the le people of Ben is
they knew nothing.
And all they had was a collection of
sayings that they had learned.
And so this is not the situation of
Islam. Islam teaches
that the prophet sallall.aii
says,
"Muslim,
seeking knowledge is an obligation upon
every Muslim. Everyone,
male and female, old and young, free and
slave, all are obligated to seek
knowledge of Islam."
A person must have at least enough
knowledge to be able to worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala properly
at least.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says here in this narration
convey of my teachings even if only a
single verse.
He says
and
relate relay the stories that you are
that you hear from beni is meaning the
people of the book
there's no blaming that but the things
that we take from
from the Jews and the Christians
If they tell us Isa said this, Isa Miam
he said this or he did this or Musam
said this or did this or any of the
prophets of Allah.
The scholars have categorized these into
three categories.
Number one, that which we know to be
true. We're sure it's true because the
Quran tells us it's true or the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
we have an authentic narration that
confirms that in that case we don't need
it from them we have it better
the second is that which we know to be
false
because the Quran and Sunnah have
said the opposite. We know it to be a
lie. We know it to be a fabrication. We
know it to be
hypocryphal.
This
is haram to narrate, haram to relate
unless it is to teach and dispel.
Then we have a third gray area which is
the most of what we will hear. That
which we don't have any confirmation for
in the Quran and Sunnah.
nor do we have any negation from the
Quran and Sunnah. It's possible
that Isaam said this. It's possible that
he did this. It's not something that the
Quran confirms nor denies and it is
possible in itself. This is what he's
speaking about in this narration. This
third type
is permissible to mention.
Is it permissible to use as evidence
we use the Quran and Sunnah as
evidence? No, of course not. Because it
is dubious at best.
It's it's not for sure. It's not
certain. It's possible. That's it.
And so to relate it as an anecdote,
sure, no problem. But to use as an
evidence to worship Allah to make it the
basis upon which you transact something
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
absolutely not.
And the third part of the narration is
then
[Silence]
and whoever
says that I said what I had not,
whoever ascribes to me what I have not
said knowingly,
then he is to assume his position in the
hellfire. meaning that this is a major
sin in Islam to claim that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said or did or
confirmed that which he did not
knowingly.
And so
this narration, this last part of the
those three sentences, this last
sentence, this is one of the most
narrated statements of the prophet
sallall.aii.
[Silence]
And really this part of the narration is
most relevant to us.
How is that?
The scholars tell us that the practice
of this narration
is that it is haram.
It is positively prohibited
to narrate a narration of the prophet
sallall.aii
that you do not have confirmation from
the scholars of Islam as being
authentic.
You hear a narration, you get a WhatsApp
narration,
right? WhatsApp narrations,
man, you will hear all kinds of things.
I could tell you some narrations I have
received on WhatsApp.
, make your hair stand up on edge.
for instance,
That's a WhatsApp narration.
The hour will not commence
until two men walk around on the moon.
Allahbar.
Some,
you know, Sephi made this up in his
mother's basement, sent it out to the
world, and then now it's Yes. Go find
this narration.
The hour will not commence until two men
walk around on the moon.
And so on. narrations of Alibab
fighting the jin underground and up in
the clouds
or that he came and ripped off this is
another WhatsApp narration ripped off
the gates of with two fingers
and then threw it behind his back.
You know was a is a stronghold right?
It's a fortress. So imagine the gates of
Ali walked open, ripped the gate out
with two fingers
this. This is how it's written. And
a person reads it and says, "Mashallah,
it's time for me to do my good deed of
the day forward."
This
is potentially a major sin in Islam.
It is not permissible
to carry on a narration without knowing
for certain that at least one
one authority
figure of the scholarship of Islam has
graded that narration authentic.
Even if it sounds good, even if it says
a good thing, even if it has a good
lesson, because we have a principle in
the science of hadith. That principle is
as follows.
That principle is as follows. Not every
good statement is worthy or fit to be
the words of the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam. There is an
extremely strict and stringent set of
criteria
for a narration to be put up against in
order for it to be able to be considered
the words of our prophet sallall.aii
Subhanahu
Saychech.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.